there's never a point in my life where I
loved my body never ever Megan Fox gets
real about how she feels about her body
the Journey of like loving myself is
going to be never ending I think the
actress is one of the cover girls for
the 2023 Sports Illustrated Swimsuit
Issue Shooting Sports Illustrated
Swimsuit is definitely a lot of pressure
and it is something that I manifested
and while Megan's confidence shines
through modeling for the cam she admits
she has insecurities about her figure I
have body dysmorphia I don't ever see
myself the way other people see me Meg's
referring to her status as a Hollywood
sex symbol double pump it squirts the
fuel in so you can go faster oh
I like to go faster hey Jennifer you
look really pretty what up Craig
he thinks he's cute enough for me
Naomi
eloquent smart way to answer someone who
keeps asking you like guys are obsessed
with you guys like your body like what
am I supposed to say thank you I'm like
God thank you like I really work out a
lot so I'm like super happy about it I
deserve it then all of a sudden I was
none of those things I was supposed to
just be
a sexy girl or the prettiest girl or the
most beautiful which is the most
burdensome uh title to have to carry
around especially when you don't feel
that way about yourself because you feel
like eventually people are going to
figure out that this is not true like I
know it's not true right now but the
shoe's gonna drop at some point and then
what what am I valued for I'm valued for
this thing which is a farce
um so it's a difficult thing to navigate
honestly and the challenge of accepting
her beauty is something Megan's been
working on since she was a kid when I
was little like that was an obsession I
had of like but I should look this way
and why I had an awareness of my body
that young
I'm not sure and it definitely wasn't
environmental because I grew up in a
very religious environment where bodies
weren't even like acknowledged when I
was young
I if I was a cute kid no one told me and
I had no idea and so I always thought if
anything I was really probably pretty
ugly
and that was just not a tool I had in my
tool belt I wasn't like Oh I'm a pretty
girl and that's something I can use to
my Advance my advantage I knew I was
smart I knew that I was funny I knew
that I was strange but in a in a good
way and those are all things that I
thought were my strengths Megan says
instead she wants people to appreciate
her inner beauty you know I guess I
could say that I wish everyone noticed
my aura because it's I have a rainbow
Aura and it's special
[Music]
um